all right well here's a quick shout out
to me hey I know that guy because well
it's me and I'm we know at good day we
love to spend time in the community
yesterday I was over with the students
at Roundy Elementary they invited me
over to talk about the broadcasting
industry being a journalist What It
Takes uh what to do so thanks to Roundy
Elementary for inviting us out there it
was a lot of fun to talk to the kids I
love the selfie style they were into it
too they were like all smiling I said do
you guys want to take a selfie and it
was just like this herd of kids all at
once crowding in behind amazing how that
works attention